>> SEAN: PROJECT VERITAS
CONFRONTED THE TEACHER AND WE'LL
SHOW YOU THAT VIDEO AS WELL.
THAT'S STRAIGHT AHEAD BUT FIRST,
OUR TOP STORY TONIGHT A NEW
BATCH OF TWITTER FILES HAVE
OFFICIALLY NOW BEEN RELEASED
ONLY MOMENTS AGO.
JOURNALIST WEISS PUBLISHED THE
LATEST DETAILS ON UNCOVERING THE
SOCIAL MEDIA GIANT'S CENSORSHIP
CAMPAIGN AND WHAT WE'RE LEARNING
TONIGHT IS DOWNRIGHT APPALLING.
NEWLY UNEARTHED DOCUMENTS PROVE
THAT LEFT WING TWITTER EMPLOYEES
BUILT BLACKLISTS OF ACCOUNTS
THAT THEY DIDN'T LIKE AND WOULD
"PREVENT DISFAVORED TWEETS FROM
TRENDING AND ACTIVELY LIMIT THE
VISIBILITIES OF ENTIRE ACCOUNTS
IN SECRET WITHOUT INFORMING
ANYBODY ON TWITTER.
FOR EXAMPLE, A POMMENT DOCTOR
FROM STANFORD WAS SECRETLY
PLACED ON THE TRANSBLACKLIST
AFTER HE ARGUED THAT COVID
LOCKDOWNS WOULD HARM CHILDREN
AND MEANWHILE OUR VERY OWN DAN
BONGINO, WAS LIMITED BY WHO
COULD SEARCH FOR HIS PROFILE OR
TWEETS.
TWITTER ALSO PLACKETS TURNING
POINTS FOUNDER CHARLIE KIRK'S
TWEETS FROM BEING AMPLIFIED.
APPARENTLY TWITTER HANDLED UP TO
200 OF THESE CENSORSHIP CASES
EACH AND EVERY DAY BUT REMEMBER,
AS WEISS POINTS OUT TWITTER
REPEATEDLY DENIED THE USE OF
SHADOW BANNING.
TWITTER WAS LYING.
THEY LIED OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
I INTERVIEWED AT ONE POINT JACK
DORSEY.
HE TOLD ME SPECIFICALLY, NO, WE
DON'T SHADOW BAN.
WE'RE ALSO LEARNING TONIGHT THAT
TWITTER FORMED A SECRET GROUP
THAT FEATURED THE COMPANY'S
HIGHEST RANKING EXECUTIVES THAT
WOULD MAKE DECISIONS IN PRIVATE
WITHOUT MUCH OF A PAPER TRAIL TO
CENSOR OR BAN HIGH-PROFILE
CONSERVATIVE ACCOUNTS.
LIKE, FOR EXAMPLE, A POPULAR
ACCOUNT CALLED LIBS OF TIK TOK,
WHICH WAS SUSPENDED SIX TIMES IN
2022.
EVEN THOUGH THE ACCOUNT DID NOT
EVEN VIOLATE TWITTER'S HATEFUL
CONDUCT POLICY.
AT THE SAME TIME, THE WOMEN WHO
RUNS LIBS OF TIK TOK WAS DOXED
ON TWITTER, THEY GIVE OUT THAT
ADDRESS, RECEIVED MORE THAN
10,000 LIKES YET TWITTER REFUSED
TO TAKE DOWN THAT TWEET.
CLEARLY WHAT MUSK SAID OVER THE
WEEKEND IS CORRECT.
TWITTER WAS AN ARM OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND A MALICIOUS
ARM.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> CLEARLY, IF TWITTER IS DOING
ONE TEAM'S BIDDING BEFORE AN
ELECTION.
SHUTTING DOWN DISSENTING VOICES
ON A PIVOTAL ELECTION THAT'S THE
VERY DEFINITION OF ELECTION
INTERFERENCE AND WHAT THE HELL
ELSE -- IT'S LIKE YES, YOU KNOW,
FRANKLY TWITTER WAS ACTING LIKE
AN ARM OF DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL
COMMITTEE.
IT WAS ABSURD.
>> SEAN: AN ARM OF THE
DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL COMMITTEE
SHUTTING DOWN DISSENTING VOICES
IS BY ITS VERY DEFINITION
ELECTION INTERFERENCE.
IT'S NOT ONLY TWITTER.
ALMOST EVERY BIG TECH COMPANY
ACTED AS AN ARM OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND INTERFERED
IN OUR ELECTIONS AN TONIGHT I
CALL ON ALL OF THEM, APPLE,
GOOGLE, FACEBOOK, ALL OF YOU
FOLLOW ELON MUSK'S LEAD.
YOU NEED TO BE TRANSPARENT, AND
BY THE WAY, WILL THE MEDIA MOB
FINALLY TAKE NOTE.
DON'T HOLD YOUR BREATH BECAUSE
AS ELON MUSK SUGGESTED ON
SATURDAY, MANY IN THE MEDIA MOB,
THEY ARE TOTALLY, COMPLETELY
COMPROMISED, MY WORDS, HIS WORD,
COMPLICIT.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> WELL, I THINK THOSE PEOPLE
SHOULD BE LOOKING IN THE MIRROR
AND WONDERING WHY THEY WERE
DECEPTIVE, WHY DID THEY DECEIVE
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC AND INSTEAD
OF TRYING TO REDIRECT BLAME, TO
ACCEPT IS SOME OF THE
RESPONSIBILITY THEMSELVES FOR
NOT BEING TRUTHFUL TO THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC.
>> SEAN: NOT BEING TRUTHFUL TO
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC.
OBVIOUSLY, BIG TECH AND BIG
MEDIA, THEY HAVE BEEN ACTING AS
AN ARM OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
FOR QUITE SOME TIME.
THAT'S NOT NEWS TO THIS
AUDIENCE, BUT WE MAY NEVER KNOW
THE FULL EXTENT OF THEIR
EFFORTS.
NOW, BECAUSE, GET THIS, NOW ELON
MUSK IS SUGGESTING THAT SOME
FILES MAY HAVE BEEN DELETED OR
REMOVED.
NOW, THIS CAME OUT AFTER MUSK
DISCOVERED THAT THE
CONTROVERSIAL X F.B.I. RUSSIAN
GATE LAWYER JAMES BAKER WAS
PERSONALLY REVIEWING AND
APPROVING THE INITIAL BATCH OF
TWITTER FILES THAT WERE PUT OUT
BY MATT -- AND BAKER WAS STILL
SERVING AS THE TOP LAWYER FOR
TWITTER UNTIL MUSK FIRED HIM
EARLIER THIS WEEK.
THIS IS A HUGE STORY.
NOW, INSTEAD OF VOICING CONCERN
ABOUT TWITTER'S COLLUSION WITH
THE DNC AND POTENTIALLY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, MANY
SO-CALLED JOURNALISTS ARE NOW
MORE WORRIED THAT MUSK STALL
BEDS AT TWITTER'S HEADQUARTERS
IN CASE EMPLOYEES WERE TIRED,
WORKING A LOT OF OVERTIME, SO
THEY WOULD HAVE A PLACE TO GET A
FEW HOURS SLEEP.
SAN FRANCISCO, WHAT'S THEIR
REACTION?
TO BEING NICE TO YOUR EMPLOYEES?
OH, LET'S OPEN UP AN
INVESTIGATION ON ELON MUSK.
THAT PROMPTED THIS RESPONSE FROM
ELON MUSK.
SO THE CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO
ATTACKS COMPANIES PROVIDING BEDS
FOR TIRED EMPLOYEES INSTEAD OF
MAKING SURE KIDS ARE SAFE FROM
FYTINOL.
ADAM SCHIFF IS SO DEEPLY
TROUBLED BY ELON MUSK THAT HE'S
NOW FLAT OUT LYING ABOUT HATE
SPEECH ON THE PLATFORM, SITING
ZERO EVIDENCE AT ALL WHATSOEVER,
SCHIFF TWEETED EARLIER TODAY,
"AGAINST SLURS, AGAINST BLACK
PEOPLE" HAVE TRIPLED ON MUSK'S
TWITTER AND TWEETS SLURS AGAINST
WOMEN ARE ON THE RISE.
MUSK MUST IMMEDIATELY POUR WATER
ON THOSE CLAIMS REPLYING "FALSE,
HATE SPEECH, IMPRESSIONS ARE
ACTUALLY DOWN BY 1/3 FOR
TWITTER, NOW VERSUS PRIOR TO THE
ACQUISITION."
MEANWHILE, THE WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY ASKED ABOUT THE
TWITTER FILES AND THE DEMOCRATIC
PUSH FOR CENSORSHIP BY PETER
DOOCY.
ALL SHE WANTED TO DO WAS NOT
ANSWER THE QUESTION AND SAY
BYE-BYE.
>> YOU'VE SAID A FEW TIMES YOU
CAN'T TALK ABOUT THE BIDEN
CAMPAIGN AND TWITTER.
WHO IS TELLING YOU THAT'S
OFF-LIMITS?
>> I'VE ALREADY HAD THAT
CONVERSATION WITH YOU, A
COLLEAGUE, I BELIEVE, YESTERDAY,
I'VE ALREADY ADDRESSED THIS
MULTIPLE TIMES THIS WEEK SO I
DON'T HAVE ANYTHING MORE TO ADD.
WE'VE LITIGATED THIS ALL WEEK.
I'M GOING TO THE BACK.
GO AHEAD.
>> SEAN: LET ME GET THIS
STRAIGHT.
WE KNOW NOW ACCORDING TO ELON
MUSK THAT THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY,
THE F.B.I., ALSO INVOLVED WITH
WEEKLY MEETINGS, WARNING TWITTER
THAT THERE MAY BE FALSE
INFORMATION ABOUT HUNTER BIDEN
COMING OUT, YOU'VE GOT TO BE ON
THE LOOKOUT FOR THIS BEFORE THE
ELECTION, MEANWHILE, THEY HAD
HUNTER BIDEN'S LAPTOP, A FULL 11
MONTHS BEFORE THE 2020
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
THEN ELON MUSK SAYS, YES,
SUPPRESSING INFORMATION IS